jake paul is getting sued in a
class-action lawsuit for promoting
safemen but there's a problem we don't
know how much he got paid so today i'm
going to answer that question and expose
all the crypto scams jake paul has done
because the list is long i've already
counted five of them
and we're gonna do a counter right here
for how much money he's taken from fans
because i may not think it's funny but i
will certainly make it entertaining for
you guys and look obviously this
information will probably be helpful to
the class action lawsuit against jake
paul and so many people are probably
wondering if i'm making this video to
make sure jake paul loses this lawsuit
and i want to be clear absolutely not
that was never the intention it's just a
happy accident let's get into this
investigation
so in order to catch jake paul i first
have to explain the challenge with
catching crypto influencers on the one
hand everything on the blockchain is
trackable and publicly available which
is a good thing on the other hand it's
super easy to set up anonymous crypto
identities whenever you want to do
something dodgy this is bad for us and
it creates this strange dilemma where
dumb influencers can be easily tracked
while smart influencers can't be because
they will just set up hundreds of
different anonymous wallets and
eventually it becomes impossible to
track what belongs to who and jake paul
is sort of somewhere in between these
two extremes he's not as dumb as you
guys probably think he is but he's also
not as smart as he thinks he is so even
though jake paul is going to try to hide
his various crypto accounts today we're
going to hunt them down and connect them
starting with this one the public jake
paul wallet the one he publicly links to
himself via openc and says was his now
before we go any further i just got to
say if you want more high effort high
quality investigations into your moms
don't forget to pump the stock eyes by
liking and subscribing it's absolutely
free you can always change your mind but
going back to jake paul's wallet there's
actually some good info here as far as
scams that we've already covered for
example jake paul got paid 39.9 ethereum
for the sacred devil's promotional scam
which you can see right here it's worth
139 thousand dollars which puts him on
the board which later linked up with a
huge ring of nft scammers we busted
actually jake paul got his fans into
buying these sacred devils and they
suffered near total losses he also
funded another nft scam from this wallet
this time his own project called stiktix
you can see him here finding the
deployer wallet of stikdix with one
aetherium and he promoted it himself
saying this
what up you dicks the community
i'm sorry violation the [ __ ] community
has grown like crazy over the past 24
hours we're almost at 10 000 spermatosa
on the discord community and we are just
getting started the result being very
satisfied customers he also got lana
rhodes to help promote it via instagram
which of course she had no problem doing
because screwing her fans is part of the
brand at this point investors and stick
dicks also suffered near total losses
meanwhile jake paul raked in 1.5 million
dollars with stick dicks even while
doing nothing he promised via the road
map now i'm sorry to say that some of
jake paul's fans were so excited about
stick dicks before it rugged they
decided to tattoo this scam on their
body this was only months before the
project was completely abandoned by jake
paul this guy says y'all like my tattoo
no no nobody likes it
now before we go on here may i say that
there seems to be something of a phallic
obsession the paul brothers have jake
paul started stick dicks logan paul
started dink doink i mean i'm not saying
it means anything but apparently if you
give these guys unlimited resources and
full creative control both of them go
straight to drawing dicks maybe it's
just a self-portrait type of thing but
look so far all this information is
publicly available but now we're going
to move to wallets that no one quite has
pegged yet and we're going to do this by
lining up some influencer posts the idea
here being that you can find a crypto
wallet if the behavior lines up enough
with publicly available information for
example we know that jake paul tweeted
about safe moon on march 27 of 2021 and
so if we check who got free safe moon at
the time of writing we can get a short
list for who might be jake paul for
example consider this wallet which got
paid 50 trillion safe moon by the
deployer wallet a day before jake paul
tweets on the 27th of march now of
course i've got to say just because a
wallet gets paid around the time jake
paul tweets doesn't mean it's him of
course so what do we do well we have to
dig for more clues so just following
this wallet a little bit it later cashes
out that safe moon for a hundred ninety
thousand dollars and sends it to a
different wallet that wallet is publicly
tagged on openc as the problem child
which is one of jake's favorite names
for himself so this is kind of promising
right you've got this wallet receiving
200 000 in safe moon and then it sending
that money over to something called the
problem child on openc but what if
that's just a coincidence well the good
news for us is as i said jake isn't that
smart so of course he used this same
wallet for more than one pump and dump
take for instance milf token which he
also promoted on may 17th without any
disclosure that this was an ad he said
i'm thinking about becoming a milf at
milf token a few days before a bunch of
tokens got deposited into a wallet which
was later cashed out at that same
problem child wallet this was sold for
fifty thousand dollars which isn't a ton
of money but further corroborates the
evidence we have but again maybe you're
thinking hey look this just all sounds
like a lot of coincidence to me so let
me give you one last piece of evidence
we have on may 13th jake paul tweeted
this everyone talking about yummy now
once again we find transactions from an
external wallet on may 13th getting tons
of yummy token for free and then on may
15th he makes another tweet about it a
year ago i talked about doge three
months ago i talked about safe moon now
i'm talking about yummy and right on cue
he gets paid once again and where does
all that money go well the same place
where he's publicly known as the problem
child and here is where he cashed out
these yummy tokens for three hundred
thousand dollars and here's where i feel
confident saying this is jake paul's
wallet and his little scheme has become
pretty transparent here's how it works
every time jake paul is going to do a
promotion he sets up a brand new wallet
just for that promotion he then gets
gifted a bunch of tokens and then that
same day or the next day he posts his
little promotion and this would have
been a pretty good scheme except every
time jake went to cash out he did it all
at the same wallet at the problem child
wallet and that was his mistake because
by building enough circumstantial
evidence against himself eventually it
became very strong not only that the
wallet that initially funds his problem
child open c wallet is publicly named on
wearable and the username is exactly
what you'd expect at jake paul the
problem child of course now i want to
thank blaine bootsy on twitter for
providing some of this research but look
what's the result of all this well none
of these promotions jake paul did were
listed as ads which is a big problem for
him and a big problem with the federal
trade commission not only that three of
these coins could easily be considered
investments which could be a problem for
the sec but ultimately i don't know what
will happen to jake will he be held
accountable for what he did for causing
losses of his fans who knows but what i
do know is that jake paul advertised
multiple project to fans without
disclosing he was paid to promote them
his fans lost money while jake was
making somewhere in the range of two
plus million dollars if you want further
evidence that his fans probably lost
money on these projects here's what
happened to yummy after he promoted it
here's what happened to milf
and here's what happened to safe mode
and of course his two nft projects are
both abandoned at this point so at the
end of the day jake paul's fans got
screwed while he got rich but i guess
anything to get that bag right we'll see
how that excuse holds up in court